talking of sequels much excitement
Channing Tatum Magic Mike to so what is
only when you tell us anything about
this it's a it's gonna be a road trip
and it's it's probably gonna be more of
the movie that you expected on the first
one is a little more bigger and funnier
and crazy just a good time on this one I
think because you'll have to get ready
to do that it is it's not a fun process
not eating anything good for about three
months straight and uh but yeah and this
is what I love because a lot of actors
if they had a kind of you know if they'd
done stripping that would have been
their secret past but you own it you've
made a you know a big successful thing
the only people were telling you don't
do this yeah yeah it was it was one of
those things that I was fine with I mean
I was 18 19 years old and and it was a
crazy time in my life and I've I've got
a chance to live crazy things and
somehow survive them so it was it was a
I wasn't really afraid of it coming up
laughing now I just want this amazes me
so in this country when people are
stripping there's very basic jobs the
strippers do like the fireman soldiers
yeah but you you chose bizarre things to
be okay well those the first ones
weren't chose for me there were more
like hazing things I think I know what
you're talking about okay your first was
your very first what a Boy Scout yes you
think that's bad this is the song he
would strip to hello Maura
and then it stops in the summer
[Applause]
the worst part about that store is my
sister came the very first night that I
ever actually try to shame me out of not
doing it I think and that was mortifying
she knew you were gonna be yeah her
friends all basically brought her and
we're trying to shave me out of doing it
but I followed through you were nervous
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
you